à présent accueillir notre grand témoin
il a été porte-parole de François
Hollande en 2012 avant de devenir son
ministre de l'Intérieur puis son premier
ministre il a créé la surprise en cette
rentrée politique en lançant un
manifeste pour reconquérir les électeurs
de gauche attachés à la République et
qui ne se reconnaissent ni en Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ni en Emmanuel Macron
socialiste de cœur depuis toujours il a
rendu sa carte la mort dans l'âme après
la constitution de la nupes au
législative Bernard Cazeneuve nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant
après cette invitation signée Stéphanie
des pierres
si on vous invite Bernard Cazeneuve
c'est parce que vous voulez refonder la
gauche sur les ruines du Parti
socialiste depuis 2017 plutôt discret
vous cultivez votre jardin les roses
sont votre passion et le droit votre
métier socialiste depuis toujours vous
avez été un pilier du quinquennat
Hollande son ministre de l'Intérieur et
surtout son dernier Premier ministre
aujourd'hui vous reprenez la parole pour
donner des coups de sécateur dont la
nupes est démontré qu'une autre gauche
est possible pas de concession sur la
question
républicaine une transformation de notre
politique pour affronter les enjeux
climatiques et la volonté de faire en
sorte que la solidarité se construise
autour de la possibilité pour chacun
d'accéder au travail et à la solidarité
de se manifester pour ceux qui n'ont pas
la possibilité d'y avoir accès parce
qu'il souffre du chômage pendant les
législatifs déjà souvent côte à côte
avec François Hollande
vous allez soutenir les candidats
socialistes qui refusent l'étiquette
nupes libération vous a surnommé les
papy flingueurs on vous connaît nuancer
modérées on vous découvre incisif contre
vos anciens camarades qui se sont alliés
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon des socialistes
ont déposé tous leurs bagages et ce sont
précipités de façon moutonnière et
grégaire vers le grand méchant loup qui
me menaçait de les de les manger tout
cru et ils l'ont fait avec une
soumission
absolue début septembre vous publiez un
manifeste de 10 pages signés par 400
élus qui comme vous veulent tracer un
autre chemin à gauche vous dites
carrément que le P c'est toutouisé un
qualificatif qui fait grimacer Olivier
Faure le premier secrétaire du PS j'ai
trouvé que Bernard Cazeneuve lapsus
presque révélateur c'était beaucoup
mélenchonisé ce qui m'intéresse ce ne
sont plus socialistes qui sont contre
tout le monde enfin qui a une espèce de
gauche qui n'aime pas la gauche qui
n'aime pas des écologistes qui n'aiment
pas les communistes une espèce de gauche
que vous êtes bien décidée à fédérer
vous lancer donc un mouvement de
réflexion pas encore un parti
bonsoir Bernard Cazeneuve bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation on va parler de votre
manifeste dans un instant et de la
gauche que vous portez au cœur que vous
aimez qui se retrouve orpheline
aujourd'hui pour partir mais d'abord on
a évidemment envie de vous entendre sur
la situation internationale plutôt du
plus dangereuse aussi que que jamais
après le discours de Vladimir Poutine
bonsoir Richard Verly bonsoir Myriam le
chef du Kremlin s'est exprimé ce matin
et bien oui Myriam c'est le discours que
tout le monde attendait comment Vladimir
Poutine ce président qui a décidé de
lancer son armée à l'assoul l'Ukraine le
24 février justifie aujourd'hui devant
son peuple cette guerre et son éventuel
poursuite alors que les conséquences se
font sentir dans tous les domaines on
sait que la Russie qui est frappée de
sanctions économiques PC de folie de
puissance au prix fort alors on
attendait cette réponse mardi soir elle
est finalement venue ce matin mercredi 7
mois pile après le début du conflit et
malgré les succès de la récente
offensive ukrainienne l'homme fort du
Kremlin n'a aucune intention de reculer
plus préoccupant encore seule la
victoire est à ses yeux envisageable on
l'écoute
nous utiliserons certainement tous les
moyens à notre disposition ce n'est pas
du bluff
alors ça ne vous surprendra pas mais
quand on écoute Vladimir Poutine
annoncer la mobilisation de trois cent
mille soldats supplémentaires et quand
on le voit annoncé également
l'organisation de référendum pour
annexer à la Russie les régions
ukrainiennes de Louhansk deniers Kerson
et zapporja des référendums qui vont
avoir lieu dès le 23 septembre du 23 au
27 une seule question se pose pour les
Européens jusqu'où aller c'est une
question à laquelle Emmanuel Macron a
répondu par anticipation mardi à la
tribune de l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU
à New York voici sa réponse ce à quoi
nous assistons depuis le 24 février
dernier est un retour à l'âge des
impérialismes et des colonies
la France le refuse et recherchera
obstinément la paix alors on l'a compris
pour le président français la diplomatie
reste encore une option pour aboutir à
cette paix que vous défendez aussi
Bernard Cazeneuve mais au vu de cet
escalade peut-on encore y croire
il faut y croire et lorsque l'on veut la
paix avec la situation internationale
est aussi tendue qu'elle l'est il faut
de la persévérance de la détermination
et du sang froid et tous ceux qui
souhaitent ardemment la paix savent
qu'ils sont engagés dans un combat au
long cours ce combat long court il faut
le mener avec de la constance la
constance c'est de continuer à aider les
Ukrainiens qui montrent une capacité de
résistance et une détermination à sauver
le leur propre droit
on l'a fait depuis le début de la de
cette guerre on continuera à les aider
bien entendu c'est de la position de la
France et c'est la position de l'Union
européenne il y a les sanctions à
l'égard de la Russie qui sont destinés à
minorer sa capacité à poursuivre son
effort de guerre
et beaucoup de débats sur les sanctions
sur les conséquences des sanctions mais
il n'y a pas de solidarité qui se
manifeste à l'égard des peuples qui
souffrent qui n'est de conséquences pour
les peuples qui manifestent leur
solidarité
ici c'est à dire que tout ce que l'on
fait en matière de sanction tout ce que
l'on fait pour faire en sorte que la
Russie n'est pas une victoire militaire
totale et pas de victoire militaire du
tout qui occasionne en Ukraine des
souffrances considérables doit bien
entendu se faire aussi par
l'accompagnement de la diplomatie aussi
pour vous Bernard Cazeneuve continue de
parler à Vladimir Poutine après les
annonces d'aujourd'hui
ce sont on peut toujours parler Vladimir
Poutine tout dépend ce qu'on lui dit si
on parle de la lumière Poutine c'est
pour témoigner d'une fermeté d'une
détermination
Vladimir Poutine et ses événements le
montrent ne connaît que les rapports de
force donc si on s'adresse à lui ce
n'est pas pour tergiverser c'est pour
manifester de la fermeté la communauté
internationale à mettre la pression
maximale sur le chef du Kremlin isoler
la Russie est-ce qu'il faut prendre au
sérieux Vladimir Poutine quand il menace
un mot à peine voilée de l'arme
nucléaire contre l'Occident ce qu'il
faut prendre au sérieux c'est son
cynisme
ce qu'il faut prendre au sérieux c'est
sa détermination à semer la guerre et la
désolation rien ne l'obliger qui
touchait à la sécurité de la Russie qui
touchait à la sécurité du continent
européen aux intérêts de son pays
enclencher cette guerre capable de
recourir au nucléaire ou cette fuite en
avant c'est le signe de son échec je
crois capable de toutes les
manifestations de cynisme mais je pense
aussi que la détermination de ceux qui
sont au côté de l'Ukraine et le meilleur
argument pour faire en sorte que la
menace reste à l'état de menace et que
les événements aidants nous puissions
par le truchement des diplomatie
retrouvée les conditions d'une solution
François Hollande en s'en souvient a
toujours dit que poutinement et que
Poutine mentait continuellement on a
quand même été sacrément aveuglé non par
le chef du Kremlin pendant des années
comment vous l'expliquez comment vous
expliquer personne n'est cru à cette
invasion ou qu'en France à part quelques
quelques experts
Vladimir Poutine moi je me souviens
d'avoir été membre d'un gouvernement qui
pendant cinq ans a vu le ministre
étrangères le président de la République
rendent compte on sait des ministres de
ce qui était la relation entre l'Union
européenne et la Russie lorsque le
président de la République a décidé avec
la chancelière Angela Merkel de mettre
en place une discussion en schéma
Normandie il l'a fait en ayant une
lucité parfaite sur ce qui était les
intentions de Vladimir Poutine et dans
les négociations qui se sont douées et
qui ont abouti aux accords de mise il y
a eu de la part de l'Union européenne de
l'Allemagne de la France à l'égard de
Vladimir Poutine une lucidité qui s'est
articulé un discours d'une grande
fermeté et qui a permis à ce moment-là
d'obtenir des accords donc vous pouvez
pas dire que la France a été constamment
aveugle à l'égard de la nuit
toujours il y a des sensibilités
françaises qui ont toujours été
tendance à être Porus qui ont manifesté
leur soutien de la diapotine qui
continue à le faire alors qu'on voit ce
qu'est cette guerre la cruauté de cette
guerre c'est leader on les connaît ils
sont à la gauche de la gauche et à
l'extrême droite
il continue de soutenir ce régime
lorsque j'ai l'occasion de m'exprimer
comme je le fais ce soir c'est un de la
part de leur soutien sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est un défaire le monde
d'insultes et de haine mais tout ça ne
doit pas nous impressionner ce qui
compte aujourd'hui c'est que l'action
qui a été engagée y compris par la
diplomatie française par la diplomatie
européenne le renforcement de la
solidarité au sein de l'Union un moment
où le continent européen retrouve
l'horreur de la guerre c'est la
persévérance la cohérence et pourquoi il
le font c'est ses responsables
politiques que vous venez de citer par
anti-américanisme par conviction ou par
simplement tactique politique en se
disant que peut-être Poutine va gagner
qu'il faudrait mieux être de son côté
non je pense que tout dans leur
tempérament la conception qu'ils ont de
la politique
certains signes le montrent dans notre
propre pays
leur fait regarder avec des yeux de
Chimène des régimes autoritaires ce
n'est pas d'ailleurs les seuls ils en
aiment d'autres en Amérique latine
au Moyen-Orient moi je me souviens
d'avoir entendu Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Mélenchon expliqué que Poutine s'était
merveilleux côté de Bachar el-Assad
qu'il allait régler le problème de daesh
on a vu comment Poutine est débachar
el-Assad a massacrer son propre peuple
vous iriez pas jusqu'à dire qu'il y a du
il y a du Poutine Jean-Luc Mélenchon non
vous me posez la question de savoir
pourquoi il y a une complaisance je
pense qu'il y a une complaisance parce
que il y a un anti mérite américanisme
viscéral qui combiné à une espèce de de
mensuétude à l'égard des régimes
autoritaires je quand je dis ça je ne
fais que de parler
de la gauche et de votre manifeste se
tournant dans la guerre en Ukraine il
intervient en pleine poussée des
populistes en Europe et oui et oui les
populistes en Europe les mouvements
souverainissent nationaux populistes ont
le vent en poupe on l'a vu en Suède où
les démocrates de Suède sont maintenant
à 20 % des voix on va peut-être le voir
dimanche en Italie alors j'étais
moi-même récemment meeting de Gênes de
Georgia Meloni la leader de l'extrême
droite italienne crédité de près de 25%
des chiffrages ça vous surprend cette
poussée nationale populiste et
maintenant des gouvernements qui sont
prêts à basculer et ce ne sont pas des
petits pays comme on dit sont des pays
importants de l'Union européenne nous
sommes souvent pas parce que c'est un
phénomène qui vient de loin et qui ne
concerne pas que l'Union européenne ce
qui s'est passé aux Etats-Unis sous la
présidence Trump était une poussée de
fièvre populiste dont on n'est pas sûr
d'ailleurs qu'elle ne se reproduira pas
ce qui se passe dans un salon de pays
d'Amérique latine je pense notamment au
Brésil c'est une poussée de populisme et
d'autoritarisme politique adossé à une
relation à la relation qui fait revivre
la nationalisme dans sa forme la plus
dangereuse et ce qui se passe en Europe
et depuis maintenant un salon de l'année
l'extrême droite au Pays-Bas en Autriche
en Allemagne avec la FD en Italie avec
la Ligue du Nord en France avec le
rassemblement national c'est un
phénomène qui s'est enquisté dans le
paysage européen depuis longtemps alors
pourquoi pourquoi cela d'abord parce que
la mondialisation et l'absence de
capacité des États et des États-nations
à corriger les effets de la
mondialisation à engendrer partout les
phénomènes de relégation territoriaux et
sociaux qui ont des conséquences sur les
populations les plus vulnérables
sentiment d'abandon un sentiment de
déclassement une impossibilité pour des
classes sociales et des générations de
de citoyens de pensées un avenir pour
leurs enfants qui soient meilleurs que
ce qui a été leur propre existence alors
que nous avions toujours vécu pendant
des décennies dans l'idée que le progrès
était possible la peur aussi
de ceux qui vient de l'extérieur avec un
processus de recroquement et de repli
identitaire et puis une perte de sens
des valeurs c'est ça qui me frappe en
France et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je mène aussi le combat politique que je
mène actuellement il a pas de
possibilité de lutter contre l'extrême
droite s'il n'y a pas d'ardent
républicain et ces ardents et publicains
ils doivent être solides sur leur base
au moment où il y a des forces de
fracturation je vais vous montrer une
image cette image c'est celle de la
nupesse le jour de sa constitution va la
regarder ensemble vous allez évidemment
reconnaître tous tous ces chefs de
parties qui ont signé pour cette
alliance au législatives vous les avez
côtoyés pour certains d'entre eux quand
on la voit cette image qu'est-ce que
vous ressentez c'est quoi ce sont des
traîtres ce ne sont plus des
républicains qu'est-ce que qui vous
voyez parce que c'est ça vous fait
quelque chose quand même mais de toute
façon la gauche rassemblée c'est la
volonté de chaque
est en réalité une république de la
relégation c'est une force politique qui
n'a aucun avenir vous dites que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon stérilise toutes les chances
de la gauche de revenir un jour au
pouvoir je voudrais aller au bout de mon
raisonnement et jamais la gauche sous
François Mitterrand sous Léon Blum
d'essence ne s'est allié avec des forces
extrêmes qui sur la question
républicaine la question de la relation
à la démocratie la question de la
relation au dictature la question de la
relation à l'Europe n'était pas dans des
positionnements clairs qui permettaient
de créer les conditions d'une espérance
jamais le Parti communiste de 1981
n'était quand même pas il y avait du RSS
en arrière-plan quand même mais lorsque
François Mitterrand s'est allié au parti
communiste il a une stratégie extra
exactement inverse de celle que l'on
voit prévaloir aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'il n'a pas placé le centre de gravité
de la gauche assez marge
il l'a placé en son centre parce qu'il
savait que c'était là qui était la
capacité d'extraction d'attraction et de
rassemblement il n'a pas renoncé à la
relation euro atlantique il a affirmé
comme une priorité Inapa renoncée à la
dissuasion il l'a faite sienne il n'a
pas renoncé au projet européen il l'a
portait donc ce que François Mitterrand
a fait c'est par la force de son talent
de ses convictions
de ces valeurs de faire en sorte que la
gauche se rallie à ce que sa grande
tradition humaniste avait toujours porté
là nous voyons tous les jours sur
l'Europe sur les dictatures sur la
République
sur le travail des tas de propos tenus
qui nous éloignent de ce qu'est le cœur
de notre identité je vois bien Roussel
s'exprimer sur le sujet
je vois certains intellectuels mais je
n'entends pas et socialistes et je le
regrette ça me peine je le dis son
bonheur aucun je ne les entendrais pas
dire
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce mouvement de
réflexion mouvement politique
aujourd'hui c'est le nouveau nom pour
les parties politiques vous allez
constituer quoi une force avec des
relais locaux pour créer une alternative
de gauche social-démocrate entre
Emmanuel Macron et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pour 2027 c'est ça l'idée que la France
ne veut pas être le seul pays dans
lequel il n'existe plus de force de
gouvernement et le spectacle que donne
la nupesse à travers ses débats
quotidiens ne me donne pas le sentiment
que cette force est arrivée à un stade
de maturité de conscience des
difficultés auxquelles le monde est
confronté et prête à gouverner le
spectacle le spectacle le spectacle qui
est donné quotidiennement aujourd'hui et
pas le spectacle d'une force de
gouvernement qui a pris la mesure des
difficultés auxquelles
et le monde se trouve confronté qui n'a
pas pris la mesure des politiques à
mettre en oeuvre pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et qui tous les
jours par le petit bout de la lorniette
avec des polémiques
inutiles qui sont très loin d'ailleurs
des difficultés des souffrances
auxquelles les Français sont confrontés
donnent d'elles-mêmes une image
d'abaissement l'objectif donc l'objectif
c'est de faire en sorte dès la campagne
présidentielle de
en politique de d'avoir un niveau
d'exigence qui permette de mettre le
débat au niveau auquel sont les enjeux
ne fait pas partie de votre manifeste je
voulais savoir pourquoi elle a signé
elle est avec vous
j'ai l'impression de stratégies ceux qui
veulent peser à l'intérieur du PS sur la
ligne et ceux qui sont à l'extérieur
de presse sans intérêt excusez-moi je
viens pas souvent à la télévision c'est
donc pas ce n'est donc pas pour cela que
je suis venu ce soir ce que nous voulons
faire ce que nous voulons faire c'est
montrer que face à la crise climatique
face à la crise démocratique face à
l'éloignement d'un certain nombre de
forces de l'idéal républicain il y a
encore des hommes des femmes dans les
territoires dans les clubs des
intellectuels qui sont prêts à mettre le
niveau d'exigence au niveau des défis si
déjà nous parvenons à faire en sorte de
parler à l'intelligence des Français de
refuser de convoquer tous les jours les
instincts de faire de la politique par
le seul truchement des réseaux sociaux
de faire en sorte que lorsque la
question climatique se pose dans sa
dimension internationale européenne avec
la gravité que l'on voit on ne réduise
pas les solutions à la question du
barbecue que l'on met les solutions au
niveau des enjeux auxquels on est
confront le populisme
n'est pas seulement à l'extrême droite
le nivellement du débat politique par
les réseaux sociaux n'est pas seulement
à l'extrême droite c'est une gangrène
qui s'est emparée de l'espace politique
monde entier et moi je suis désolé je
vais pas je vais pas m'excuser lorsque
je m'exprime de vouloir faire en sorte
que le débat soit porté au niveau des
enjeux et je vais pas m'excuser de
respecter les Français et de vouloir
parler à leur intelligence plutôt que de
laisser aller au débat qui semble
occuper aujourd'hui toute la gauche
depuis maintenant deux ou trois jours
quand ce n'est pas ça c'est autre chose
et qui donne de la gauche et du paysage
politique français une image assez
triste parler à l'intelligence des
Français c'est aussi les convaincre de
revenir aux urnes
l'abstention et la crise démocratique
est très importante le spectacle qui est
donné actuellement et de nature a donné
envie aux Français de revenir aux urnes
comment vous allez convaincre et vous
pensez que les jeunes notamment Bernard
Cazeneuve
d'information en continu de ses débats à
l'infini et le questionnement
systématiquement le même des acteurs
politiques lorsqu'ils sont interrogés
etc et nature a conduit les Français
quand elle continue à voter qui attend
d'être rassuré qui a toujours des
solutions face au richement
réchauffement climatique face aux
angoisses de l'avenir notamment et qui
quand on regarde les enquêtes d'opinion
se tournent soit vers Jean-Luc Mélenchon
soit vers Marine Le Pen en priorité
le mode radicalité est-ce que vous le
faites votre on l'entend beaucoup dans
cette dans cette jeunesse française
pas par hasard décide de
fonder la République pour couper tout
lien avec la monarchie de mettre en
place école pour tous de séparer
l'église d'État on est dans une
véritable radicalité mais cette
radicalité c'est pas un extrémisme
c'est un corpus de principe de valeurs
qui structure une société avec la
volonté d'ailleurs de faire en sorte que
cette société trouve son unité et donc
moi mon problème c'est pas la radicalité
quand elle prend conscience des
difficultés du monde et s'inscrit dans
une démarche qui est destinée à créer de
la cohésion et de la force c'est
l'extrémisme c'est l'outrance c'est la
violence verbale c'est l'abaissement du
débat c'est la préhension de tous les
problèmes du monde qui sont immenses
systématiquement par le petit bout de la
lorgnette c'est ça mon problème vous
avez un nom pour votre mouvement
on va y réfléchir collectivement mais ce
mouvement se mouvement de réflexion moi
ce que j'ai envie c'est c'est de sortir
des appareils nécrosés c'est de sortir
de ces débats qui n'intéressent plus
personne c'est d'ouvrir les portes et
les fenêtres et de faire en sorte que
l'on puisse avoir dans des mouvements où
l'on respire ou l'on se respecte moi je
ne pratique pas l'ex-communication quand
je dis ce que j'ai à dire sur la
République ou ce que j'ai à dire sur le
réchauffement climatique ou sur la
politique énergétique immédiatement le
discours est le même que celui qui
s'adresse d'ailleurs à Fabien Roussel si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec la ligne
générale c'est que vous êtes de droite
ça ça s'appelle le sectarisme avec sa
contrepartie qui est l'excommunication
vous voulez que les personnes
du Parti socialiste des députés vous
rejoignez 90% des signataires de cette
motion son manque de partis politiques
du Parti socialiste des radicaux etc
donc moi le Parti socialiste c'est ma
famille je reste viscéralement attaché à
cette famille et si j'ai pris la
décision que j'ai prise c'est pas parce
que je voulais m'en éloigner
c'est parce que je voulais que le fleuve
retrouve son lit et demeure fidèle à sa
source comme disait on va suivre de près
ce nouveau mouvement de réflexion ce
mouvement politique qui qui veut
conquérir cet espace j'appelle tous ceux
qui ont entre la France inscrivent dans
la tradition de Pierre Mendès France a
rejoint ce manifeste et à le signer pour
nous aider à faire en sorte que nous
puissions retrouver un peu d'espérance